and so we are in relationship  in the seeming form of another person  with ourselves what we try to do is we  point the finger out there we make it  about the other person we try to change  the other person and we don't change  ourselves ego whose beautiful job is to  keep us safe and protect us from getting  hurt again ego wants everyone else to  change  and not to change we want everyone else  to change and not to change and that is  the sort of self-reinforcing mechanism  and intention of ego  because the fear of if i change or my  perceived sense of self change then who  will i be and so change for ourselves  which is why we resist unconsciously and  it's a beautiful intention change feels  like a death  to who i am so rumi said in order to be  free you must die before you die